foreign
the sound of explosions over Kiev the
night sky lit up by flashes City
officials say Ukrainian air defense
systems intercepted dozens of Russian
drones and missiles in the early hours
of Tuesday mobile phone footage filmed
by a resident shows the intensity of the
attack
we heard it all even our Windows shook
but thank God there were no missiles in
our area
oh my friends my classmates and I we
heard it all they were all worried and
one of my classmates houses got hit I
think it's terrible
the attacks came just hours after
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
returned by train from a trip to Europe
aimed at securing new weapons and
support for an anticipated
counter-offensive
we are returning home with a new
military help newer and more powerful
weapons for the front more protection
for our people greater political support
no one knows when the counter-offensive
will begin but Ukrainian troops are
preparing in the south of the country a
multi-units say they're ready but need
more weapons
offensive because currently we use basic
Jeep models which are not armored an
armored car would provide safety for our
servicemen that's what really matters
even its supporters hope that this
counter-offensive will be successful
since Russia's Invasion Ukrainian forces
have exceeded expectations pressure is
high but the reality is that few believe
that this push will be the last or will
win the war Natasha Butler Al Jazeera
leviv Ukraine